Rogers stone is on the phone laughter
welcome back to morning ladies and germs
that's are you feisty welcome back to
Jim Norton and Sam Roberts great to be
with you guys again
how are you holding up well it's like
that movie Groundhog Day it's 2019 I'm
still under federal investigation by you
know two and a half years the government
reading all my emails all my text
messages listening to all my phone calls
and still they have no evidence of
Russian collusion WikiLeaks
collaboration or any other crime it just
seems to be never-ending I won ellen
carlson last night and talking about the
impact on my family and my business and
so on it's you know it's right up there
with a plaque biological examination I
must tell you is one of the great
experiences of all time it sure is you
bet you don't tell that to the come on
my life so Roger how did you feel I saw
you you you got to they mocked you in an
episode of Family Guy recently and that
was that greater well it seems like look
see what you're wearing it as a badge of
honor
yeah there's four stages the same yeah
our who is Roger stone get me Roger
stone right get me a Roger stone type
who is Roger stone hmm
so I'm kind of in Phase two at this
point Saturday Night Live has a has a
segment coming up on me that they've
been promoting pretty extensively you
know the only thing worse than being
talked about is not being talked about
do you think the president is handling
the shutdown well yes actually I do you
know he's a very stubborn guy very
stubborn I don't mean that in a negative
sense but when he sets his mind to
something and anybody who says we don't
have a problem there that the fact that
you know enough Fenton all came over to
our southern border to kill every man
woman and child in the country over the
last year I think that's a problem
the fact that they say Oh only six
terrorists got into the country six
really how many were that were involved
in the 9/11 attack on the country so
they were on Billy
the right thing and frankly I think
leather I mean Nancy Pelosi's not doing
that almost misspoke there yes you did
we're the 9/11 terrorists on airplanes I
think so yeah okay so well they didn't
come in that way or did they they came
in the car doesn't matter how they came
in any time you're building along Hanan
terrorists in the country illegally it's
a potential danger to the country so
when terrorists would be one terrorists
too many it only takes one to shoot up a
shopping mall yeah but I think like the
people are bringing up 9/11 because
they're saying that the wall that they
built in Mexico would not have prevented
the 9/11 people from getting in right
but nobody but nobody said it would what
we're saying is that the presence of
terrorists who were in the country
illegally regardless of how they got
here
is a bad idea look I I just did all
these Democrats Obama Nancy Pelosi
chuck-e-cheese Schumer all supported a
border wall at one time they're just
against it now because down from flora
just like they didn't like the war in
Syria Avery didn't like war at all most
liberals I know were anti-war it's
always kind of been that way yeah until
Trump announced that he was going to end
the war in Syria and bring our troops
home now we're against that because
Trump's for it or even better the
criminal justice reforms lately you know
recently which in all honesty I've been
arguing with Donald Trump for years
about this issue and the disparity and
sensing between you know black people
poor people disadvantaged people who are
using rock cocaine and people who are
using powdered cocaine there's much
harsher mandatory penalties for rock
cocaine for example I couldn't get
anywhere on this Kim Kardashian waltzes
into the Oval Office and boom it's done
Wow but I don't care how it got done
it's the right thing to do right yeah
and there's a you know 710
african-american members of the House
all Democrats voted against it because
Trump was for it they've always been for
it but now they're against it cuz Trump
did it it's a manifestation of krump
derangement syndrome
yeah I'm not actually arguing any of
that by going back to the boat
talking about before if we're
anti-terrorism we should probably be
paying the TSA right well you know I got
mixed emotions about that they kind of
bubbled the surface every time I'm going
through it's funny how they stop me and
go through everything in my bag but the
guy behind me with a turban holding a
box a ticking they let him walk right
through it's very strange well yeah I
think that they get me on the random
quote-unquote random stops - I think
those random stops are just so who they
can actually technically stop whoever
they really feel like it and claim it
was random but we do we are supposed to
have the TSA no yes let's face it you
kind of have that criminal look so I
could see why they might no I I
understand believe me every time I'm
parked in front of a grade school
there's an issue they just want me out
Roger do you think it's an issue that
all the airport folks are not in pain
getting paid you know the problem is I
don't know how effective that program is
to be honest with you I don't I honestly
don't know how many bombs they've
actually found or how many you know I'm
not sure guys that's relying on their
rules
you notice that Oh a cigarette lighter
you can't have this your laptop has to
come out your laptop has to stay in your
iPad has to come out your iPad has to
stay in I don't know how effective all
that is but it seems to me that the
president keeps making compromise
proposals yesterday he offered two days
ago I guess now you offered to give them
what they want on daca and return for
the wall funding assuming to me a good
compromise where everybody got what they
wanted and Democrats wouldn't go along
did he offer everything back from daca
or just a temporary relief I'd have to
go back and look at it but I thought it
was a pretty substantial offer but it
wasn't quite what they had been asking
for right so all right so give Trump
four billion instead of five point seven
let's get somewhere right right we sure
we do need to get some where both sides
are being stubborn for sure I was happy
to see that even with everything that
you have going on right now mr. Roger
stone that you were still able to get
out your much-anticipated
annual best and worst rest of the year
list yeah I you know this gets harder
and harder to do I I'm now in my 13th
year needs to be done by a guy named mr.
black
right it was he was a Hollywood designer
and he would always put out a list of
the very best and worst dressed people
in the country and his criticism could
be withering you know he could destroy
your career I don't have that kind of
oomph but I do try to compile this list
during the we're and let's let's face it
once you saw Michael Kohn sports jackets
you knew he had to be on the list do you
think there were good jackets no I
didn't know ralston purina was making or
the sports jackets to be honest with you
what's interesting and I would never
accuse anybody of bias not on this
ideology tyent I doubted no not at all I
don't I don't think in Jones from CNN
was on my best dress I'm right here with
a guy on anything I don't think so
either I don't think that there's bias I
just think you know here's the some of
the names on Roger stones were stress
people of the year and it's tough to
argue her Lena Dunham Michael Cohen
Mark Zuckerberg baito
O'Rourke Steve Brannon ago Steve Bannon
known right-winger we I mean he's not
hanging out with Jeffrey Epstein yeah I
know I think that your history with
Steve Bannon is not you know yeah I I've
never known you guys to be on the most
familiar in past years for exactly Rand
Paul has been on my worst dressed list
he was on it last year I looked at my
best dressed list you got you got Van
Jones for example that's true that's
true I've had ears Anderson Cooper has
been on the list and he gets an
honorable mention this year Mike
Smerconish not exactly a flaming right
winger no from CNN so I think the list
is never been ideological Ted Kennedy
was on it when he was alive mm-hmm we
had that Ivy League all-american looked
at he shared with his brothers it's
really not ideological it is is strictly
built on on on style I mean let's face
it you can argue that Lena Dunham
doesn't look like she dresses out of a
dumpster yeah it's a tough argument it
would be a tough one to win especially
the photo that you posted let me see
Lena Dunham
I always enjoyed her outfits if you
scroll up to the top of the worst list
section
Troy you'll see Lena Dunham and there
she is
yeah I mean she does scroll down she's
black yeah oh yeah that's Lena Dunham
not a great often no not the best outfit
in the world but why Cam Newton
Cam Newton didn't raise him like a
stylish in the in the photo that you
posted it's a form-fitting out it's not
it's never very well put together he
needs to get advice from Shannon sharp C
sharp has moved into our our lifetime
achievement category you've been on the
list so many times so you can be big and
muscular and you can mean athlete you
can be very well turned out like say
Dave Beckham who makes the best list now
I've never heard anybody calling Dave's
Beckham before no I mean all right David
what did you what do you know for
example Audrey Gelman who is a
democratic political operative in New
York City one of the best dressed women
on the face of the planet she's on the
list so it's really not at all
ideological it's based exactly gets
harder and harder to do every year that
because there's so many people just
don't care but don't and John you put on
John the worst dress but it doesn't he
kind of do that on purpose like just
loud flashy performance that's like
getting mad at a rodeo clown because he
dresses bad at his job yeah look we've
given him a pretty wide berth but you
know if you're gonna wear athletic
tracksuit she should be somewhat
athletic it's the way he does in his
casual life he does wear a bad clothes
he's put all he's put a couple of pounds
all you had to you know the picture they
have is him on stage he looks like he's
a bit half that's truly is 110 years old
yes I was reading you know all these
articles last night about the leaks and
the White House and who the leaks are
and the newest one that I've read is
people think that Kellyanne Conway is
leaking information about Trump to the
press for some reason tried to her
husband and pillow talk and he tells cuz
he hates Trump very possibly do you
think Kellyanne Conway is responsible
for the leaks Rodgers Donna I really
don't know nor for 30 years I just don't
think that's her style and and she just
has no there's no there's no motive for
her to crap where she eats to be honest
with you I think she's one of the ones
who doesn't leak if you want to find the
leakers look for the Bush Republicans
look for the look for the the deep
Staters who have gotten managed to get
jobs in this administration so I really
doubt that she's a leaker that's just an
opinion do you think she's embarrassed
by her husband being so [ __ ] vocally
against her boss how could you not
I mean I'm not sure you know that must
be a very interesting marriage I'd like
to hear that pillow talk because you
know he's entitled to his opinion but I
think he's particularly nasty and he's
not in the public realm he's a he's a
trial attorney where she is I think it's
somewhat unfair and most of his
criticism is wrong when I read it
how does Trump tolerate that like you
know does she does she bring him to the
White House for like dinners or things
like that I would think not
he probably doesn't do a lot of the
family activities I would say I would
think not
that is so girls I think the president
understands that one is not responsible
for the political opinions of your
spouse you're only responsible for your
own political opinions do you think she
should dump him I would I mean look at
the guy but you know what do I know
he didn't make your worst-dressed list
knows he didn't make the worst-dressed
list no he's not that bad I mean first
of all I it's hard to even find a
picture of the guy he just think is his
attacks are gratuitous I don't get it
yeah he's an attorney yeah you would you
do you think it's distasteful to make
gratuitous attacks on people you
wouldn't do anything like that right
never had ever done it in my life okay
good good I just wanted to you clown put
put that on the record what do you think
speaking of uh of gratuitous of all the
coverage of the manga had kids the the
Catholic high school kids that were
looking at the Native American thank God
for the internet and video cameras
because you know if this happened in
1970 there'd only be one narrative the
narrative controlled by the three TV
networks and we'd all be told that this
brave Native American Vietnam war hero
was menaced by these mean high school
students from Kentucky but thanks to the
wonders of the internet and video camp
we now know that's not the truth and is
kind of hardening to see Jake Tapper and
others retreat yeah because everybody
jumped out there with a completely false
narrative
I believe me I know how this is I mean I
it's great to wake up in the morning and
read every other week you're being
charged that day and go to jail I had
Newsweek report that I was in plea
negotiations with robert muller not true
i had CBS report a month ago that i
would be charged and arrested the
following day refused to refuse to
retract so there's a lot of fake news
out there i remember did a whole
half-hour last night by the way here's
the worst breasts of anybody glad we're
not cartoonists you can always tell when
I remember is lying his lips are moving
this side
it was always holding up Randi credit
goes on once a week once a week to say
he wasn't Roger stone source regarding
the significance or the timing of the
WikiLeaks disclosures until I produce
text messages that prove indisputably
that he was boom he's gone re never says
his name again he doesn't even exist so
now it's Jerry core cos you've seen this
guy looks like a fish I mean this guy is
is out there just lying his ass off
about me all the while trying to say I
will never tell a lie I'm the new George
Washington meanwhile the guy is in there
spilling his guts saying all kinds of
things that aren't true about me none of
which is supportable other thing other
than the memory that comes from his
alcoholic haze and I can prove we text
messages emails metadata tags on his
documents that he's like compose it so I
mean it's just it's just another day in
the life of Roger stone Roger I know you
don't like hypotheticals but you know I
always throw these hypotheticals at you
and I would just like to know and this
is just I don't know I'm sure you
haven't even thought about it because
this is not gonna happen
okay for the record I don't think this
is gonna happen but let's say again you
got bamboozled we're talking hoodwinked
hoodwinked we're talking the West
Memphis Three
we run amok led astray led us straight
the an innocent man has gone to jail and
you do six months from now let's say you
get completely framed and bamboozled and
you get put in jail would you do you
think if
that were to happen you in us as an
innocent man you go to jail do you think
you would still work on a best-dressed
war stress list for this year from jail
so let me ask you this when you're
leaving the studio tonight today when
you get popped for possession of
marijuana would you oh pardon me I don't
like these hypothetical Claire I know
let me just say regardless of what
happens right the international best and
worst dress will be produced every New
Year's Day the rest of my life okay good
it's a staple I think it's necessary I
think that would be the thing that
people were most worried about if you
were to go away for a long time people
would go like well how are we gonna know
who the best and the worst rest is
that's right mr. Blackwell anymore and
you go don't worry about it they can put
me in pinstripes I'm gonna be the best
dressed guy in pinstripes well you know
what they say they can put me in jail
but they can't stop my face from
breaking out that's right that's a very
good expression what do you think there
Joe what do you think they're gonna do
with Julian Assange they're a little
tired of him I mean you probably toggles
the mind I mean Julian Assange is a
journalist and he definitely publishes
information that's embarrassing to the
government he's embarrassed both
Republicans and Democrats he's published
a lot of information that embarrasses
the Russian government interestingly
enough but they seem to be bent on this
narrative that he's a Russian asset well
that's a nice you know that's a nice
theme coming from the same people who
told us Sodom Hussein had weapons of
mass destruction but there's no evidence
to prove it there's no court decision
that proves that it's just a charge in
America you're innocent until proven
guilty nobody's proven that I think his
great sin is that he's embarrassed power
very very powerful people all my friends
who were liberals loved him when he was
embarrassing the Bush administration now
they think he's you know he's a criminal
but if you if you convict him of
publishing classified information well
then you have to charge the New York
Times in the Washington Post and The
Wall Street Journal he's oh uh you know
I it's in my own best interest for him
to come here and be questioned in all
honesty because he would tell you what
he's already said
he never had any communications with me
I had no advance notice from the source
or the or the content of the WikiLeaks
disclosures the one exchange we did have
over direct message on Twitter I turned
over to the House Intelligence Committee
go read it they brushed me off so I you
know he put out a comprehensive
statement about ten days ago where he
flatly denies any communication with me
that's accurate but aside from aside
from all that is like I've always
wondered is Julian Assange a good meal
companion or yes just like so much
information that it gets boring yeah
does he have a good matter having never
met the man I couldn't tell you I do
think he's got a lousy existence I mean
don't get the idea that the Ecuadorian
Embassy is somehow opulent right this
guy is basically been in the same closet
for seven years
yep no sunshine no exercise can't leave
the grounds essentially in a virtual
prison so they have posters I'll cut off
his internet access you know the guy
can't even play video games does he have
posters up in his room
couldn't tell you haven't been there oh
that's right do you that do you think
what are you working for me all right
that guy can't dress either by the way
that Mueller no he can't he's so good
he's not a fashionable guy well Roger
stone yes we always really don't
necessarily agree with that he's got the
Brooks Brothers button-down thing down
pretty good do you get are you tired of
people wearing these form-fitting suits
now cuz I know you're an old school guy
you just wish people would go back to
wearing like the big the bigger almost
like a zoot suit no that's not true it
depends on your build in other words the
the silhouette of your suit the style of
your suit should be based on your
physical physicality if you're a young a
thin guide and one of those
close-fitting suits can look very good
it can be of the Thomas Brown look on
the other hand you know if you're if you
were built like Henry Kissinger you
should probably be wearing something it
drapes a little bit it all has to do you
look this all up in my book stones rules
because it's covered very extensively
but it has to do with your bills right
it's rates it should flatter you at the
end of the day exactly and a great
tailor can hide your flaws well I'm
looking for one then yep yeah all right
Roger well thank you for calling as
always yeah you're always fun to talk to
Roger and
we want to help the stone family can go
to stone Defense Fund dot-com because
every dollar I can scrape up has to go
to the lawyers yes Roger they are they
are harassing him he that these legal
fees are very expensive you should help
him and you never know when this is
gonna be the last time he calls the show
so we really appreciate it everything I
think help Roger gets what helps us
that's right that's a hundred percent
right
thank you very much Roger thanks guys